Here's to nothing getting in the way of our adventure.
Emily I can't go to South America.
Wait. Wait. What?
My band is really blowing up right now and where i'm going
Τhere's gonna be like a ton of
Inspiration
Pussy
Inspiration?
No, pussy
I keep talking over you but it's sounding like your saying
Pussy
Inspi..I heard it that time
You poor thing,
you look awful
Thank you
We'll get through this
This is long hug
All right
Uh, ok
Mom, look how fun you were
Pack your bags, we're going to South America
Absolutely not
Everybody knows you need two years to plan a vacation
You don't do anything fun anymore
That's not true! I've been taking sculpting lessons at the Why.
Da da!!
I told you i would not acknowledge that
That is frightening and you made that
Ok
Hola!
Checking for Middleton
What's this?
Welcome
Wel what?
Oh, welcome!
They're not serving
Aww sorry!
I've got it
Why are you dressed like a beekeeper?
Sun is dangerous
Mom, you put so much on
You put so much on!
We're going out today
I'm definitely not
You're gonna miss this whole trip
Everything shouldn't be so scary
Hi, I'm James
That was not what it looks like it looks like
It looked like you were washing your vagina in the sing
What I need is an amazing adventure
Where the hell are we?
The senior groups
Why did you come to South America?
I never wanted to come at...
...for the cultural experience!
I don't speak any Spanish.
I know what they call me at the restaurant
Puta, which means princess, pretty or...
No, it means whore.
That check's out.
I'm going to get us out of this
No man who can take care of you
that's a sex slave start - okay mom - if people want
young beautiful female you are both safe
you would be so lucky to fuck us kid
No I would be very unlucky
You're like melted candles